now we got to get to Mitt Romney eating
a hot dog
really important stuff
speaking of the Senate Mitt Romney
posted this video a few days ago it has
gone viral
well as you all know today is National
Hot Dog Day and perhaps you also know
that hot dog is my favorite meat I love
hot dogs I love them in buns I love them
outside of buns I love them with baked
beans I just like hot dogs it's the best
you know best meat there is without
question so to all of you who like me
are celebrating a national hat Hot Dog
Day uh congratulations to you and may
there be many many more hot dogs served
in our wonderful land
did you catch it if you were listening
you didn't catch it I know he sounds a
little stilted it has a little bit the
aspect of how do you do fellow humans
he's wearing a hat that's got a hot dog
on it he's walking around with the hot
dog it's a little awkward but kind of
charming and endearing actually by the
standard of Mitt Romney did you catch
the problem though there's always
something with this guy
and here's the problem
ketchup
he's got ketchup on the hot dog
of course he does of course Mitt Romney
puts ketchup on that I don't want to
read
too much into Mitt Romney's hot dog
tells you a lot about his politics
though
no person over the age of 18 really no
person over the age of 14 or 15 should
ever put ketchup on a hot dog it is
sugary sweet it destroys the delicious
taste and flavor and complexities of the
hot dog a hot dog is meant to be enjoyed
with
chopped onions or relish I'm not a big
relish guy but some people like it
sauerkraut I I need sauerkraut on a hot
dog mustard but not ketchup ketchup is
for little children
and
this reflects Mitt Romney's politics
Mitt Romney's politics are for little
children Mitt Romney's politics are for
for people who don't want to play in the
big leagues
Mitt Romney's politics are
so
eyed naive
innocent or perhaps
cynical Mitt Romney is the kind of
Republican
who
either always allows himself to get
duped or concedes from the very
beginning what made your political fight
has Mitt Romney ever won for the
conservatives
none
he invented Obamacare that was
unfortunate he
was run rough shot over in the race
against Obama
and he spent the last seven or eight
years attacking Republicans consistently
in undermining conservative priorities
maybe that's because he really believes
what he says and I've given the benefit
of the doubt maybe when he says we just
need to meet in the middle and be really
conciliatory and come on haha work
across the aisle or maybe it's because
he just thinks there's no viable path
for conservative policies or maybe he's
just a liberal himself and you know but
either way
when it comes to conservative fighting
he behaves like a child and apparently
he eats like one too right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles you know a company
is looking out for you when they upgrade
your service and they don't even charge
you for it well that's what Pure Talk
has done for new and current Pure Talk
customers pure talk just added data to
every plan and included a mobile hotspot
with no price increase whatsoever if
you've considered pure talk before but
haven't made the switch take a look
again for just twenty dollars a month
you will get unlimited talk text and now
50 more 5G data plus their new mobile
hotspot this is one of the many reasons
I love Pure Talk they're veteran owned
and only hire the best customer service
team located right here in the great us
of a most families are saving almost a
thousand bucks a year thousand bucks a
year imagine what you could do with that
while enjoying the most Dependable 5G
Network in America remember you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
don't support you go to puretalk.com
save an additional fifty five zero
percent off your first month because
they actually value you that is
puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans buy Americans
right now go to goodranchers.com use
promo code Knowles you know that I love
anything made with top of the line
quality I am a simple man I am easily
Satisfied by the very best when it comes
to me that is good ranchers period I
have good ranchers every two or three
days now I think and probably the only
reason I don't have it more is because
I'm on the road a lot the other night we
had beautiful good ranchers filet mignon
and ribeye and my only complaint about
the dinner was that my little
one-year-old baby was gobbling up the
rib eye faster than I was
you've got to check out good ranchers
okay the the one thing that you might
say has been missing from good Ranchers
steak is great the Burger's unbelievable
the chicken's great you might say Well
they're missing pork until now good
ranchers just launched their Prime pork
100 American pork that is Steakhouse
quality new pork box comes with bone-in
and boneless pork chops sausage smoked
brats more right now you get 30 bucks
off with my code Knolls
goodranchers.com they got everything the
prime beef the prime pork the better
than organic chicken it's just the
greatest goodranchers.com use code
Knolls
goodranchers.com use code Nails get 30
bucks off any box
goodranters.com American Meat delivered
there's another very serious candidate
waiting in the wings not even declared
yet that candidate would be
Glen yankin remember Glenn yankin
there have been two very very impressive
governors in the last couple of years
Rhonda Santos of course in Florida
Glenn Younkin in Virginia
Glenn youngin wins his race in Virginia
which is a blue Commonwealth
by running well initially he tries to
run on just cutting taxes
and all that business Country Club kind
of Republican stuff and he was going
nowhere and then
young can leaned into more of the
cultural issues
critical race theory in schools
bathrooms in schools daily wire broke a
story
on that latter issue and that story and
that issue may have thrown the race to
Glenn yankin 's there and
inside every Governor is a president
just waiting to come out so junkins
looking at it he's reportedly meeting
with some donors in fact he's meeting
with Trump's former Commerce Secretary
Wilbur Ross hosting a meet and greet for
Glenn yankin Glenn yankin has no
shortage of wealthy friends he was the
co-ceo of the Carlisle group I think
it's the largest private Equity Fund in
the world they they had this meet and
greet at Wilbur Ross's Southampton or
they're having the meet and greet at
Wilbur Ross's Southampton home and what
is youngin doing here is he declaring no
is he starting a Super PAC no but
he reportedly sent word to Trump
that he's only making these moves so
that he can be in the discussion and in
contention for VP
again this is all just according to
reports from the New York Post and some
other places now
but assuming those reports are right
this is a smart move for junkan because
if you're Glenn young you're thinking
okay in many ways I'm comparable to Ron
DeSantis Rhonda Santos is more
conservative than I am Rhonda Santos is
more effective than I am but Florida is
also more conservative than Virginia is
so given our relative States okay I'm
doing okay but but DeSantis is being
just ground up in the Donald Trump meat
grinder as would any candidate and so I
want to put myself in a position where I
could be the president especially as
Donald Trump's facing three indictments
he's probably gonna face 30 more by the
time the election comes around so I want
to put myself in that position but if I
want to put myself in that position
without also getting ground up by the
Trump campaign machine then I need to
directly coordinate with Trump and say
hey bro I'm not threatening you
I'm not gonna run if you're running
as much out of self-interest as out of
any kind of loyalty don't worry I'm on
your side in fact I want to help you in
fact I want to be your vice president
that's a smart way to play this
and it's something that
the other candidates I think did not
sufficiently take into account in this
primary race you can see Vivek is
playing pretty nicely with Trump he's
reserving more of his criticism for the
number two candidate Ron DeSantis and it
seems to have benefited him in the polls
the Trump campaign
is brutal it is brutal it will
especially if their candidates way way
up right now and the candidate is
running effectively as an incumbent
they're going to chew people up so Glenn
young can very smart says he only wants
to be BP of course he has no designs on
being president this cycle but it's a
long ways to the election and there are
a lot of indictments coming down the
pike
we could end up in a situation very
plausibly end up in a situation in 2024
where the two candidates for the major
parties are neither Biden nor Trump man
what a great clip that was if you want
more of those clips and episodes and yes
or no game and two and a half hour
interviews with horn hat guys and all of
it you gotta ring the bell subscribe to
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time